hey everybody thank you so much for
tuning in to another edition of market
takes i am dion robowen thank you for
being with us here on youtube uh we are
doing a live stream to kick off the week
talk about everything that's going on in
financial markets uh the big stories
that you all need to be watching out for
if you're interested in the market if
you're interested in the economy if
you're investors if you've got money
that's sitting in a savings account
somewhere this impacts you too so thank
you so much for tuning in to market
takes this morning uh you know i know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and i
appreciate that uh look we have a huge
massive enormous week this week we get
not only the april jobs report which is
going to come out on friday we also get
the fed meeting on wednesday meeting
actually tuesday and wednesday but
wednesday is the day we get the results
from the meeting and fed chair jerome
powell's press conference
so this is going to be a big week which
is going to tell us a lot about what
we're in for the rest of the month
likely the rest of the year we are i
think going to get a lot of information
about the economy
and about what to expect in the markets
and i think investors are going to make
a lot of decisions based on what we get
this week so definitely a week to tune
in and remember this week
because i think it's going to be a big
one and a very important one you know
the market action that we saw for the
month that just ended in april i think
really tails the tale tells the tale of
why this week is going to be so
important so i want to dive into that a
little bit just to kind of explain what
we've been seeing so far this year i
think april was a real microcosm of
everything that we've seen so far this
year and why this upcoming week is going
to be so important so
last week
last week of april as we closed out the
first month of the second quarter and
the fourth month of the year a really
tough week for stocks a really tough
week for the stock market and really
ended a tough month you saw last week
the dow almost down almost nine percent
for the month of april that was the
worst month since march 2020 and the
doubt or the s p 500 actually went back
into correction territory as we start
the week today we are still in that
correction on the s p 500 s p actually
just a little bit lower today uh so
that was actually the worst april the
worst month of april the market has had
since 1970 um and we saw the longest
weekly losing streak continue last week
since september 2020 so again we're
seeing the market very clearly moving in
a negative and down direction
friday just as a day the largest one-day
loss since june 11 2020. none of these
are good signs and the s p was bad but
the nasdaq was worse we saw the nasdaq
down more than 13
in april the worst month since october
2008 the worst april since 2000 uh if
you are an investor and or a market
participant with uh with a memory you
know that 2008 and 2000 are not years
that we want to be drawing comparisons
to and friday on the on the nasdaq the
worst day since september 3rd 2020 but
we're not just seeing the sell-off in
stocks we're also seeing a sell-off in
bonds we saw the 2-year treasury yield
those government bonds the 2-year
treasury yield up 41 basis points
for the month of april yield's been up
for nine consecutive months not only has
the yield risen for nine consecutive
months and remember as yields rise
prices fall so that means bond investors
losing money but it was the biggest jump
in the yield since 1994 for a nine month
period so that's just a huge sell-off
for the two-year treasury and we saw a
similar thing in the 10-year treasury
the two-year rose almost two percent um
just over these past nine months out
just year to date excuse me so just over
the first four months and a little bit
of change that we've seen so far this
year that's a massive gigantic move i
can't overstate how big a move that is
in the two-year treasury yield the
10-year treasury yield has been up for
five consecutive months year-to-date
it's up 140 basis points that's 1.4
percent that's just a giant massive huge
move but also gold having its worst
months since september 2021 so those
traditional safe havens usually when
stocks sell off investors move into
bonds they move into gold things like
that those have both done poorly and
investors have been selling out of those
and you're seeing big drops in price
there as well the one thing that did
well was the dollar the wsj dollar index
which looks at the dollar versus 16
other currencies that had its best month
rising almost five percent in april uh
best month and biggest percentage gain
since may 2012 biggest points gained
since october 2008 and why that matters
is that's the dollar compared to 16
different currencies so you're seeing
the dollar getting stronger folks moving
money into the dollar and out of those
foreign currencies across the world and
saying you know what i want the dollar i
want the global safe haven i want to
move into the world's reserve currency
and this very safe asset
again telling you all that because i'm
getting you ready for what we've got
coming this week this is the live stream
thank you all for tuning in we are
seeing a massive sell-off in stocks in
bonds and in gold last month and we've
seen that really for about most all of
this year really and going back into
late last year so again we're going to
be describing and dealing with we've
talked through the market reaction now
i'm going to talk about why this
upcoming week is going to be so
important here on market takes on the
live stream so what we've got coming
this week like i said we've got the jobs
report the non-farm payrolls report from
the labor department that's coming out
on friday before we get that we will get
the end of the two-day meeting by the
federal reserve on wednesday fed chair
jerome powell is going to come out and
say hey here's what we decided he'll
hold this press conference we get a you
know just the the announcement on rate
hikes we're seeing expectations for the
fed to raise rates at twice the normal
pace that they do
and we'll we'll find out i mean the
market is has pretty much priced that in
almost entirely but we will get
confirmation that on wednesday we'll
also hear from the fed chair who will
take us through
what he's thinking and what the board is
thinking on wednesday
sneaky important release this week is
the fed's report on consumer credit that
g19 report i told you about a month ago
to watch out for that report because i
thought it was going to tell us a lot
about the economy it did for february we
get the report from march on friday look
out for that i think that's going to be
talking to us as well so
let's get into it right this week we get
the jobs report the april non-farm
payrolls report which comes out on
friday i think that's going to be a very
big and very important report
for the for the pace that it tells us
about where we are in pace of jobs last
month we saw a another big report more
than 400 000 jobs added to the us
economy this month expectations for a
similar number do we get that but also
more importantly what do average hourly
earnings look like what's the pace of
wage increases for folks in the us
economy because when economists like fed
chair jerome powell and he's not a
trained economist but he leads the
biggest economics institution in the
world probably that's the federal
reserve
when economists like that point to
things like the increase in average
hourly earnings the increase in wages
and they say this is looking a little
too hot
there's a reason for that it's wage
increases are generally stickier as in
they stick around
longer than other increases for
inflation so as some other things like
increases in the price that you pay at
stores price that you pay at the pump
rent increases things like that those
tend to dissipate a little more easily
than wage increases and we're seeing a
big pickup there so when we get this
report on friday i think all eyes are
going to be on average hourly earnings
which we'll find out that recently has
grown at about 5.6 pace
very high very elevated but
keep in mind that that's not keeping up
with the pace of inflation which is much
higher
again the the hiring pace as well we'll
also get the jolts report this week
which an undercover very important
report but it's delayed by a couple
months so we will get that report this
week as well that's going to tell us how
many hires there were how many people
quit their job but also how many job
openings there are and we've seen a
consistent trend of almost two to one
job openings per unemployed person does
that continue because you can't fill all
those jobs and businesses are saying we
need workers and they're hiring right
but they're not hiring at a pace fast
enough for them or to even get us back
to the pace of employment that we had
before the pandemic hit in march 2020 so
we're gonna see on friday
what the pace is of job hires uh what
the pace is of employment gains as well
as what the pace is of those average
hourly earnings what the paces of wage
increases that workers are demanding and
more importantly the workers are getting
so that's why i think this is going to
be a very big report again job support
is out on friday expectations are that
we will add 375 000 jobs in april after
431 000 jobs were added uh the month
before in march
so continued pace of around 400 000 jobs
a strong pace but not a pace that's
going to get us back quickly to
recouping those jobs that we had getting
us back to the employment level that we
were at in february 2020 and again as i
said the most important piece that
release i think is going to be the
average hourly earnings number now all
of that matters because it matters to
the federal reserve and we hear from the
federal reserve and fed chair jerome
powell on wednesday the fed has really
ratcheted up expectations for the action
they're going to take if you remember if
we rewind to about a year ago the
federal reserve was seeing rising
inflation because we've seen
pce and cpi which are the two big
inflation reports they've risen pretty
consistently for more than a year if you
look at the pce personal consumption
expenditures report that has risen every
single month since december of 2020. and
so around then it was going at about 1.6
1.7 then we got to 3 and the federal
reserve was saying hey we think
inflation is going to be transitory we
think that it's going to be temporary
all these impacts of supply chains and
issues like that are all coveted related
we think this is going to go away
naturally we don't need to raise rates
then you saw kind of the end of last
year start of this year the fed saying
okay you know what this isn't going away
we're going to retire that word
transitory we now need to start raising
rates we're going to start doing that as
we get into this year as we've moved
into where we are now in april or in may
now i guess of 2022 the federal reserve
is saying yeah we're going to have to
raise rates we're gonna have to raise
them fast
for this upcoming meeting the
expectation is for a 50 basis point rate
hike the federal reserve normally raises
25 basis points at a time to kind of let
those rate hikes similar in simmering
let the economy get used to that so
you're not overheating things but
now they're saying look we are behind on
inflation we we need to we need to act
fast and act quickly so we're going to
do 50 basis points likely
fed chair jerome powell will never say
this is officially what we're absolutely
going to do but he said we're looking at
that it's on the table the market has
priced that in at over a 99 probability
according to the fed fund futures market
so markets have said this is a foregone
conclusion they're going to raise rates
50 basis points not only that
the market has said they're going to
raise rates at 75 basis points as in
triple the normal pace at the june
meeting and then another 50 basis point
increase at the next meeting in july so
the market is saying these 25 basis
point rate increases that's not going to
be enough the federal reserve is going
to have to go much faster than before
and we will find out we'll hear from the
chairman himself on wednesday whether he
is in agreement with that or whether he
says uh you know pump the bricks we
don't we're not that far behind we don't
need to go that fast uh but likely you
know if he doesn't raise rates at 50
basis points there's going to be a lot
of explaining to do markets are probably
going to go absolutely crazy i don't
think that's going to happen because
this federal reserve has been very clear
about setting expectations what they're
going to do and keeping to those so we
can we can likely expect that but what
happens in june what happens in july
what happens at their next meeting in
september
this is going to set the table for all
of that what we hear from the chairman
on wednesday so
that's going to be big the markets are
going to move be sure you can count on
that you can set your watch to that but
we'll see just where it goes um you know
we've seen just recently on friday the
shadow open markets committee which is a
company or it's a group of folks that
watch the fed they held a meeting with
three former presidents of the federal
reserve and they pretty uniformly said
we don't think the fed can slow down the
economy without causing a recession we
don't think the fed can do what needs to
be done to tame and reign in inflation
without causing a recession and we'll
see federal federal reserve chair jerome
powell may have to push back on that
because he and the rest of the fed have
said we can achieve a soft landing we
can bring things in but we're seeing it
right now in things like the mortgage
market right where rates are above five
percent on an average 30-year fixed rate
mortgage rising pretty well above five
percent now uh we're seeing this in
stores everywhere where we're seeing
inflation and the big question right now
is has inflation peaked we saw that cpi
report uh for the last month that we got
it eight point five percent uh so right
now year over year prices are rising up
eight and a half percent um but we
started to see signs that that might be
peaking and then coming down if you look
at the core pce report and the core
report on that cpi
those showed that the month over month
numbers within the cores and when you
take out volatile food and energy prices
you know because those jump around they
move around a lot if you strip those out
the core rate of inflation what you pay
for goods which pay for rent things like
that is slowing down and coming to a
sort of stop so we did see that but
other reports are suggesting that ah
maybe this isn't slowing down or peaking
we saw the ppi which is producer price
index that's the price that businesses
pay for goods that hit an all-time
record high
when it was when we got the report in
april for march so that's continued to
rise higher as we know when inflation is
high businesses pass those costs on the
consumers and will that continue will
that continue to drive consumer prices
higher also housing reports we saw a
number of those showing that prices for
houses are still rising at that 15 to 20
percent pace that they were rising at
last year that's not going to suggest
that housing prices will cool off or
that rent prices will cool off shelter a
big component of inflation so again we
get we got this fed report and we've
we're going to hear from the fed on
wednesday we're going to hear from chair
powell on wednesday
we're going to get their rate decision
and that that's obviously going to move
the market then on friday we get the
jobs report also that consumer credit
report coming out on friday be sure to
look for that the march increase in
consumer credit is expected to be very
small last month or when we saw the
report from february it was 42 billion
dollars increased consumer credit
expecting just about 2 billion or 0.02
billion dollars increased this month
which would suggest that that spending
in february was just pulled forward if
that happens then it's likely you know
everyone can calm down but if we see
another big increase in consumer credit
that could be worrisome
so i want to thank you guys again for
tuning in we are going to wrap things up
here on market takes i am deon robon
markets reporter at the wall street
journal
again this week look out for that jobs
report on friday the fed meeting on
wednesday that starts tuesday will end
wednesday that's going to move markets a
lot but don't sleep
on that g19 consumer consumer credit
report on friday week's not over after
we get the jobs report so be sure and
stay on your toes for that
look i want to thank you guys all for
being a part of my live stream for
joining me today we will do this again
next monday and we're going to keep
doing it every week as long as you guys
keep tuning in so i appreciate that like
i said could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and i hope
you'll be with me again next week on
monday
i'll see you around